paint Hudson dating the NFL's most
eligible bachelor JJ Watt the football
superstar has been linked to Katy Perry
Tori Kelly and tennis player Caroline
Wozniacki
well I Kate has been known to have a
thing for athletes I mean there was
Yankee star Alex Rodriguez yeah and pro
golfer Adam Scott
so Carly still got Kate to set the
record straight about JJ how do you guys
know each other oh oh we actually just
have the same agent we've read like we
were like a big dinner ya know we've the
same yeah same agent you also have a
great group of girlfriends I said -
Gwyneth you guys have the blonde tirage
holy the blonde dress when you're
drinking social barriers who is the
fussiest with photo approval I'm pretty
fussy really no I feel like you should
never post without getting someone's
permission you know when you're in a
group photo and there's one friend who
won't be happy with that picture but
then you're like but I love it I'm
always like everybody needs to approve
it here's what I wonder if you guys get
remarried
does it mean the ring has to be bigger
I'm saying yes in her new movie Mother's
Day the 36 year old is besties with
Jennifer Aniston but as her lone
relationship with director Gary Marshall
which is coming full circle you have
known Gary Marshall since your mom
filmed over for such a memorable
experience cuz Gary kind of creates this
family-oriented setting you know and and
sets are really boring for kids
there is eight-year-old Kate looking
anything but board behind the scenes of
the 1987 film and there was her brother
Oliver Marshall telling us that Kate is
following in her mom Goldie's footsteps
Kate was little and got my way but she
sat on my lap and we yelled action
together
/ time and now in this movie without two
kids they sat on my chair and we all did
it we talked to Garen he's here he got
really teary talking about you being on
set with your mom sing action now writer
on this set same action riders now gets
it like he is out the Adria's like oh
you want to watch everything now he's
like okay now he's like okay not just
pretty yeah he's like maybe an extra
paid has been open about her struggles
as a Hollywood mom and Mays in style a
single mother of two confesses quote
sometimes I feel like a bad mom
everybody can always do more as a parent
it's a hard thing when you're a working
mom and you're thousands of miles away
from your kids and they're doing things
that are important in their life that
that you can't be present for is a real
thing I think at some point we have to
say you know it doesn't make you a bad
mom it's so tough juggling everything
right